do all mentors want to get paid so I got
a great question front of my YouTube
viewers love you guys Daniel who wrote
in to say how should I proceed to find
the mentor most mentors want to be paid
for coaching and if I was like 15 years
old don't have money how do we do it so
this is a great question and mentors are
fantastic resource for you to shortcut
your path to success whatever your goal
is whatever you want to accomplish
whatever hurdles you're facing right now
in your life in your business finding
somebody who's already busted through
those and have reached the goal that you
want to reach and having them coach and
mentor you along will dramatically cut
down the time you're gonna take to get
to where you want to be the number of
mistakes you're gonna make it's just
overall a great thing that you want to
try out and mentors can come in the form
of real-life people who you're
connecting with and having coffee with
two people who you learn from from books
and videos and movies and people you've
never met but one thing that's really
important when we're talking about
people that you're meaning live
face-to-face people that you look up to
the you respect you want their opinions
you want their coaching you want their
advice they don't necessarily want money
but they want value for their time and
what I mean by that is everybody wants
to feel like to have it an impact right
especially as you get older you want to
feel like you're doing something to make
the world a better place and mentoring
is a great way to do it the challenge is
a lot of mentees they're honestly not
ready they're not ready to put in the
work and the time and the commitment to
make it valuable so you want to make
sure that you're bringing value to the
relationship that you're making that
mentor feel like they're giving back so
have three bits of advice for you
number one is start with coffee people
make the mistake of emailing or calling
up somebody that they've never met that
they look up to saying will you be my
mentor you have to understand that a
mentorship is a serious relationship
maybe we're not getting married but it's
as serious as dating at least you should
take it that seriously because a good
mentor they'll take it that seriously so
you don't just jump into a relationship
with somebody having never met them
right that shows your level of ignorance
that shows that you're not really
committed to this because I would never
jump into something neither should you
if you don't really know that person so
start small and start with coffee say
I'm starting this new business or
whatever your goal is and you know I
respect everything you've done and show
some examples to show that you've
actually done some research on them and
I'd love to be able to pick your brain
over coffee it's on me if you have half
an hour 20 minutes any day next week any
day next month whenever it is I'll show
up I'll be there with a smile on my face
ready to absorb all of your knowledge
and wisdom okay show me some passion
show me some excitement show me that you
actually know who I am and ask for a
coffee start off the relationship small
make it easy to say yes and then start
giving value so one start with coffee
number two is bring passion and
execution and this is honestly where so
many people fall down okay the value may
be ask what value do I bring to a mentor
this is a two-way street and you have to
understand that the value that you bring
to a mentor is them being able to impart
knowledge on you and you'll be able to
go take action on it right they want to
see your face light up with the idea
that's great that gives the instant
gratification that brings a passion out
but the execution actually go out and do
what I tell you to do right you're
they're asking for their advice if you
want an ongoing relationship you need to
go out and actually take action a mentor
doesn't want to be just constantly
coaching and being motivational so yeah
you could do it go you can do it I
believe in you rah rah rah they want to
see you're actually doing work they want
to be able to give you practical things
say go out and do XYZ and you go out and
do it
and you do it faster than they thought
they were gonna take right
get out there and do it for them that
gives them the sense that you care and
they're giving back that's the value
that you bring they should see you they
should look at you and the energy that
you bring and that energy revitalizes
them make them feel passionate about it
again and they look at you and they see
a younger version of themselves
that's what you want them to see that's
the value that you bring so remember to
always bring the passion and then go
execute and the execution may be hard
it's not going to just be some simple
strategy it's gonna be hard it's gonna
push your comfort zone it's gonna make
you do things that you're not
comfortable with that you may have never
done before that you're scared of but
that's what you need to do to grow
that's what you need to do to get to
that place that you want to be and if
you're not willing to do that then don't
go out and get a mentor because they're
gonna drop you before you can drop them
passion and execution and number three
is join a program you could do a lot of
great research on your own and reach out
to people and ask questions even this is
a start right you're asking me a
question responding and trying to help
you out what's the value that I get I
like knowing that I'm helping
entrepreneurs you know are you gonna go
out and execute on this I hope you will
a lot of people won't that makes a
difference between the ones who become
successful and the ones who don't they
have the courage to step outside their
comfort zone and execute so you can do
it on your own like you're doing now or
you can also look for programs
especially for young people there's a
lot more mentorship opportunities so
look at you know whatever school you're
at look at whatever government programs
are look at if there's any companies
that are offering mentorship programs
there's a lot of these programs and
nonprofits that have been set up to
specifically guide young people through
their career path and giving them advice
and connections to mentors and specific
programs so if you want to become an
entrepreneur there's a program for that
if you want to become a lawyer there's a
program for that right so they have
specific programs that can help you as
well do you research to find them and
apply and get in and see if it's for you
it's a it's a great supplement to you
going out and reaching out to mentors
directly on your own so in summary how
to find the mentors it's not just about
giving them money but you got a number
one start with coffee
number two bring passion and execution
number three
join a program
and believe for those of you watching
like a video you can subscribe to the
channel to see more videos just like
this thank you so much for watching I'll
see you soon
and don't forget for my best information
join my newsletter and get on the
believe team today hi I'm Jason Grif on
sigur rós online.com and I want to say
Evan Carmichael's newsletter is
consistent fun inspiring and XP only
newsletter I prioritize and look forward
to period